- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians,
historians, and linguists.
David here with Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi.
- [Voiceover] And Jake.
- [Voiceover] Hey.
- [Voiceover] And we're gonna talk about
the history of the apostrophe.
The apostrophe isn't
just a punctuation mark.
In fact, the word apostrophe
comes to us from Greek,
from two different compounds.
"Apo," meaning "away," and
"stroph," meaning "to turn."
So it's a turning of strophe.
We need to turn away.
So it's a turning away.
And in rhetoric, in classical rhetoric,
when we talk about apostrophe,
it's turning away from
your actual audience
to deliver a message to absent people
or inanimate objects or
just non-personified,
you're trying to personify
an inhuman concept.
- [Voiceover] So before
it was a punctuation mark,
it was a literary technique.
- [Voiceover] Yes, it was a turn,
it was a figure of speech.
You know, so if you think
about examples from literature,
this can be, the two things that my mind
immediately leaps to, being me,
are "O, happy dagger,"
the speech from the end of
Romeo and Juliet in act five.
Boom, sorry, y'all didn't see.
I plunged the stylus into my breast.
(giggles)
"O, happy dagger, this is thy sheath."
"There rust and let me die."
Boom.
So, like in that, like, you know,
we're addressing the dagger.
The dagger is not alive.
It is a knife.
It cannot respond.
Or, on a lighter note perhaps,
from H.M.S. Pinafore, there's a song,
"Fair moon, to thee I sing,
bright regent of the heavens."
It's the moon.
The moon can't talk back.
And from this figure of speech,
this is where we get the idea
that an apostrophe represents
something that is missing.
That's how we come to get its main use,
to represent that something,
that it's standing in for absent letters,
just like an apostrophe in rhetoric
would be delivered to absent friends.
Follow me over to the next screen.
Let's do a little bit of history.
So the apostrophe was introduced
to the French language
by an engraver and humanist
named Geoffroy Tory,
I think, is how you would say his name.
That's a guess.
And around the late 16th century,
I think it's around the 1580s,
Tory is the man who also introduced
a lot of diacritic or
accent marks into French.
So, you know, instead of
like, "aime" meaning "loved,"
it would be "aime" like that.
And he's the person that
used it originally in French
to start representing eliminated letters.
So if you have an
expression like "la heure,"
meaning "the hour,"
Tory would have it "l'heure," like that.
You know, and this
apostrophe in there, boom,
represents this missing vowel sound.
So, okay, so it's around this
time that this apostrophe
starts making its way into English,
because remember, England
has been under French rule
for centuries at this point.
The French invaded in the 11th century.
We're talking about the
Norman Conquest of 1066.
And since then, French culture has had
a very profound impact on
the island of Great Britain.
You know, so everyone
in a position of power
speaks French or understands
and reads French.
So the nobility speaks and reads French.
Anyone that's literate
speaks and reads French.
And so you're gonna be, you know,
this intelligentsia is going
to be coming into contact
with a lot of French,
see the apostrophe being
used this way and say,
"Oh, that's awfully convenient."
And so it's around this time,
around the early 17th
century, late 16th century
that we're starting to see this
apostrophe usage in English.
This is around the time when you first see
the contraction of "I am,"
"I'm," show up,
is around this period.
Jake, does this square with
how apostrophes are used
in other languages too?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's
the same in pretty much
all the Romance languages.
So anything derived from Latin,
you have in Latin these
long definite articles
like "ille," i l l e,
or "illa," i l l a.
And all the definite articles
that come out of this
in all the Romance languages
take some fraction of
the original from Latin
and omit some part with an apostrophe.
So "amico" in Italian,
to add a definite article
to make it "the friend,"
you can add just l apostrophe.
"L'amico."
- [Voiceover] Cool.
So yeah, so during this time
of apostrophe expansion
across the continent,
people are just going nuts, right?
There's no standardization
of usage for apostrophes.
People are using it every
which way, but loose, you know.
So they're using it like this.
They're using it for contractions.
They're using it for multiples of stuff,
like stuff that we would
consider incorrect today.
Like "book's," like that.
Wah, that looks terrible to me.
And crucially, they're
using it for the possessive.
So like, "Jake's."
And the history of that usage
is another story entirely.
But this, for now, is the history
of the introduction of the
apostrophe into English.
You can learn anything.
David and company out.